With the "Friends" reunion special debuting
on May 27th on HBO Max, fans of the beloved
sitcom are practically buzzing with anticipation.
Meanwhile, the cast has been doing promos
ahead of the special's release, including
a video interview with People, in which they
reflect on their time on the show and the
personal friendships between cast members
that have lasted throughout the years.
Fans most excited for the reunion have likely
been devouring all the "Friends" reunion content
they can get, which is why many of them noticed
something ... off.
The interview with People, which is about
eight minutes long, features all six of the
original cast members - Jennifer Aniston,
Courteney Cox, Lisa Kudrow, Matt LeBlanc,
Matthew Perry, and David Schwimmer.
However, of the six cast members, Perry seemed
to talk the least, remaining quiet for the
most part and often looking down or away.
While his castmates seem jovial and animated,
Perry's demeanor is more subdued.
From what little he did contribute, his speech
seemed to be off, slowed down, and somewhat slurred.
Fans picked up on these details right away,
and began speculating about the actor's health.
Knowing that Perry has a history with substance
abuse - including during his stint on "Friends"
- fans in the YouTube comments expressed their
concern about Perry possibly having recently
relapsed, or that he might be experiencing
depression related to his recovery.
One commenter wrote,
"I just wanna hug him and thank him for all
the laughter he's responsible for till this
very day and say how special he is."
Another user, expressed similar sentiments,
writing,
"I wish Matthew Perry so much solace and peace,
he's been through so much and I really appreciate
him doing this appearance for us.
What a blessing to have them all together."
The top comment on the video reads,
"I wish we could make Perry as happy as he's
made all of us."
Fortunately, the cause of Perry's slurred
speech and mild demeanor is reportedly not
related to his addiction, but rather an unrelated
medical issue.
While neither Matthew Perry himself nor his
official representatives have confirmed these
claims, an anonymous source spoke to The Sun
about Perry's speech and appearance.
The source revealed that Perry's speech was
due to an emergency dental procedure, which
occurred the same day that the interview with
People was filmed.
Because it was of an emergency nature, the
interview couldn't have been planned around
his procedure, nor could proper recovery time
have been allotted beforehand.
Perry’s a pro, he just had the procedure
and simply decided that the show must go on, it seems.
The source told The Sun,
"Matthew turned up to the reunion and members
of his team said that he had an emergency
tooth procedure that day.
That was said to impact his wellbeing and
also how he was feeling.
He had been in pain from what we understand,
which caused the slurred speech."
The source also addressed the comments of
concern online and reiterated that,
"Matthew has told those around him that he
is sober, and there is no need to worry."
In the past, Perry has been outspoken about
his struggle with addiction, as well as his
recovery and sobriety.
Perry struggled with addiction to alcohol
and pills, including during his time on "Friends."
He has even stated publicly during an interview
with BBC Radio 2 that he doesn't remember
filming three full seasons of "Friends," stating,
"Somewhere between season three and six ... I
was a little out of it."
To treat his addiction, Perry did two stints
in rehab during his time on the sitcom, in
1997 and 2001, and in 2011 he returned to
rehab to continue working on his sobriety.
In 2013, he told People that he turned his
former home in Malibu into a facility for
men's sobriety, stating,
"The interesting reason that I can be so helpful
to people now is that I screwed up so often.
It's nice for people to see that somebody
who once struggled in their life is not struggling any more."
If you or someone you know is struggling with
addiction, please call the Substance Abuse
and Mental Health Administration's 24/7 National
Helpline at 1-800-662-HELP.
That's 1-800-662-4357.